I genuinely believe that Google would
offer you a job that like stands pizza
shop wouldn't I think we're in this
bizarro world where so much is happening
that it's that it's not the box that the
three of us grew up in this portion is
like with me so I think this is one you
need to get selfish like you'd ask your
question
hiring is guessing firing is known like
you gotta go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's a bigger step out this
is the television and the television is
the radio before these [ __ ]
let's actually now get into like some
detailed questions this is time to go
very narrow very narrow to your business
so this year I found out for myself
what is the most important thing or what
is the yeah what is the engine of a
successful company and in my opinion
it's a company's culture so this is in
my opinion the engine that makes
successful companies so successful and
in my opinion the base for it is open
feedback culture then to be creative to
give the room for experiments and on the
other hand like yeah reward the single
persons for what they do and I wanted to
ask if there is something more well
first of all I love what you just said
for a lot of reasons one I agree to I
love that you gave both a social like a
Democrat and a Republican answer which
is right which is why I like the fact
that you understand that like that
culture and soft things matter but then
also the merit and rewarding right like
that that is what America and Germany
for that matter and many other places in
the world are struggling with which is
the answers both and everybody for some
reason thinks it's one or the other and
they're in contrast I think I think
you're on it I think you're on it I
think the the last thing that matters in
my opinion is that it's being built for
the long term you know obviously you've
listened to different stories you've
gone through the scenario of selling
something when you were to CEO of that
company based on the way I was listening
to the story maybe or maybe not doesn't
really matter but probably you came in
with knowing
that was a viable option and if that was
the case then he was building towards
that he kept I don't care about
vaynermedia's ebody does I've never
thought about it once because I'm not
selling it gutless you know because I'm
not selling it so all of a sudden I mean
you know I talk almost every single
employee here is not a functional PL op
like my CFO probably doesn't want any of
the people in this room to be here
because it's not to the core revenue
driver of the thing but that's not the
mission that I'm on so I think this I
think you've got it at least from what I
heard and they're all anything we add is
really just adding to the left or the
right and intuitive like in here you've
got it I would say the only
vulnerability you have to culture is if
you and your founder are thinking about
selling this company to BMW - you know
Harley Davidson well you know I'm not
educated up but the only thing that
could [ __ ] up somebody that understands
the balance of left and right is that
all of a sudden they've made a switch
and they want to sell the company in 24
months which then changes a lot of their
behavior you know if you get an offer
cold and some banker hits you up and
they're like we're gonna pay you twenty
three million dollars for this business
and you're excited we made this up 5
years ago can you believe this you know
and then all of a sudden you go to the
next phase you're like okay they're our
thing that's 23 because they're offering
us seven point three times our three
million profit what if we wait a year
and get it - six million in profit then
we'll get a forty five and that's where
[ __ ] gets [ __ ] up
in culture oh by the way you guys may
want to sell it for forty five but
that's the only other variable in this
conversation it's the balance of left
and right and then if you're lucky
enough to go in perpetuity you can
really build something like I am but
that also isn't for everybody you guys
are such a maybe have 43 other ideas
that you want to do and that's the
beauty of getting to choose your path
it's the only other variable left
I'll fill in another part of the story
please interested in hearing your
perspective on it so when I was in my
second stop as a public company CEO as
shaken by my board understood and went
through a very deeply personal attack
that's how it usually happens yeah I'm
not gonna go into it but I got ugly yeah
but it got ugly and we're a guy that
would robust yep and you're charged by
the SEC as a company yep
etc etc we we were mediated it actually
self-reported we did all the right
things but at the end of the day they
hit us with a massive fine and you have
to carry that kind of about some letter
level what a scarlet letter understand
was at the very end yeah you know
chairman of audit chairman call me
honest arrows out golf and my son it was
young and they said listen we got to
talk and I said okay but I actually we
have disclosed it so I had a week where
I was out there mm-hmm
basically telling everybody that I was
buck stopped with me happened on my
watch this is what happened I get it
so you know a client problems we had all
kinds of a twitch shareholders who were
clients right so is a we were in the
equity business understand so they came
to me and said listen you know Bob it's
nine years we had a 10-year succession
plan maybe it's time to make the change
said great no problems oh by the way
we're not going on your contract right
we're gonna there's two words for you
yeah cuz the second one you yeah okay
huh and I you know it just turned into
an all-out war of course so see one of
the journal Monday morning gas realized
the board fired you know yeah and so it
was a very public understood yep so we
through a year and you know for me I was
lucky because I had a lot of friends who
stood up for me and ultimately buoyed me
but a year of that like a vacuum yeah
and being able to tell my side of the
story right sown into arbitration I won
they had no choice it was it was this
was a public everybody board running for
the hills
yep threw me under the bus so that was
about four years ago but it's one of
those things you know you you that's
still hovers yeah well actually not in
my new business
nobody cares anybody know
right it's not like the first result on
Google that you're worried about kind of
thing it probably is up there actually
the first result is you know I was hired
by Barclays yeah so the second was I
understand and they never really fully
reported it mine I understand I'm not
even too worried about I want to know
where you're going so where I was going
with it was you know it's four years
yeah some of you wake up with every day
right it's just something you just you
know it's just like nausea right it's
Naz because you've you can feel your own
behavior being affected by the concern
of something like that again now I've
learned I learned a lot right that makes
sense
despite the fact I've been a public
company CEO for 11 years yeah never saw
it coming which I'm very disappointed
myself but it's a it's that reputational
kind of how do you how do you go about
you know reconstructing your reputation
after something like that I know if
you've done crisis management I have
real thoughts on this like real thoughts
it's uh it's it's really simple it's
offense not defense you need to
there's only if we were best friends
from the Jersey Shore we would have
dinner and this is literally what I
would say for Batum brother I'm no
[ __ ] idea how much true or how much
not true of any of this is because I
don't you need to go on crazy offense
and produce unlimited content on podcast
and Linkedin about this I only have one
advice as my best friend 100% the truth
so if you've been kind of keeping one
percent for me and you're one you're one
percent you are completely vulnerable to
one thing the margins in which you've
kept like everyone of us like I mean I'm
really getting goose bumps it's in the
margins of what you kept and you're
talking to somebody who desperately
understands human behavior desperately
that is your vulnerability that is your
Jail that 1% could be 50% you could be
[ __ ] completely lying I have no idea
but honestly like life is life like like
my level of judgment these days
I was never good at judging people now
that our entire culture is only about
judging people I think it pushed my
point oh one left to zero that's what we
do all we do is go on Twitter and judge
each other left and right headline a
judgement judgement judge
I mean a woman in the UK today said I'm
a terrible person because she squeezed
shot one glass door review and decided
that's the truth of what's going on
these four walls like that is what we
live in that's fine but now I'm at zero
like I just like outside of murder like
outside of the core egregious things in
our society I can't get you know like
I'm like in tilt right so the answered
your question and something I watch very
carefully and I think a lot about
personal brand I also know that one day
every person hurts gonna know who I am
and I have to start already mentally
practicing for when I'm a human and I do
human things and make a mistake what my
move is gonna be your only vulnerability
is that percentage that still isn't out
there from you acknowledging accepting
or even the money is shot saying
something that easing out there the
other true the core honest truth that
the lord of the Lord's understands is
what you have to put out at scale and
then you're [ __ ] free as a [ __ ]
bird well that was that week so so you
know there's never been a Wall Street
CEO on the planet that has ever taken
full responsibility for anything that's
happened to this firm I was the only
okay if you look at blank fine time and
you go down the finest so anything that
this happened in deep inside the firm
blah blah so that's that's something I
feel very good about right which was it
was all out in the open in the public
domain me whose opinion do you care
about at this point because we're all
humans I understand like like who's the
people that search your name it's work
that's why I went there
yeah you need to produce content at
scale I highly recommend as a friend as
a Jersey boy I'm already your friend to
really really really go there with one
manifesto right like really go there
yeah further than it is my
responsibility delicacy use the NDA
respect then like allude and reference
and then produce content of scale so
that look you're it's very hard to Trump
the Wall Street Journal on Google so
you're gonna have to put out a lot of
content for a long time but look I'm
gonna say this and this might be a this
is the actual back to the real game
versus the tactical game is content at
scale that eventually allows enough
other things to offset it right actually
I'm glad I reference it Glassdoor last
door like I could incur like I've I've
six employees here again you know me as
a human being and love me as a man as I
like the [ __ ] boss who've not left a
positive review on Glassdoor
it's very easy for me to spend seven
minutes to get a hundred reviews in the
bunch it's the punchline is the truth is
the game and so you can either get
tactical or you can get real real macro
on this and actually understand this
biggest truth I think that second result
and I get it is no different than a 14
year old with a huge [ __ ] pimple go
in high school she and he are so [ __ ]
scared about that pimple and walking
into school what they don't realize is
everybody's got their pimple brother
nobody gives a [ __ ]
Prince died and he got 24 hours of the
new cycle and that's it if you think
anybody gives a [ __ ] if you think your
future kids in law let's go deep like
everything they don't give a [ __ ] you're
gonna have six conversations and you're
on your merry [ __ ] way nobody gives a
[ __ ] the reason it's so easy for me to
take so much criticism is because I
don't think hear the criticism or the
praise that's the game nobody cares bro
good news there's so much egregious [ __ ]
happening in our society that they don't
give a [ __ ] they don't care absolutely
they don't care the way we grew up right
it's just changed and if you feel like
you've put out everything you can
I would I would challenge you between
the it's fully my responsibility and the
NDA in a LinkedIn post around something
macro of like
a manifest of like things I've learned
in the last decade and you put it in
there so I'm going yeah so yeah it's
it's interesting because I was just
asked to speak to the biggest securities
yep industry group about being a public
oh yeah I think I think I think you go
look I think you go 100% accountability
yeah I I think honestly but you know
what I mean listen I'm we're talking and
up here like like I think where you can
really win these games is it's an it's
human nature to spend eight percent of
the time to fifty percent of time on the
board member that really wanted you out
because they're shorting the stock
behind it but like whatever it might be
whatever it might be I think the unlock
is 100% accountability I got too high in
my own supply and and pay attention I
kind of you know like real [ __ ] like I
should have went with my [ __ ] senses
I kind of felt there was something
brewing but you know I got caught up in
the rat race of every 90 day numbers
like real [ __ ] real [ __ ] you know real
[ __ ] put it out there you know it's not
fun for me to put my [ __ ] out there but
like I don't want anybody have leverage
you know yours is real fun for me
because I think you have this kind of
like wildly fun blank canvas and I
actually think it's a very practical
exercise of a P&L I think you literally
first of all I would highly recommend
moving to a place that is not expensive
to live if you're arbitrary thing is
America and outdoors I get really into
like Idaho you know and maybe you're a
little bit you know to Calgary down like
[ __ ] that like I don't wanna be a cowboy
anymore like I don't know but like to me
it's like when you're a generalist I
actually think it's a strength because
it means you're comfortable into many
different things I just think it depends
on how you want to make your money but
like add on to the context so I can give
you yeah so like yeah it's it's funny
cuz I forget your podcast with the other
day but basically said you're a
psychologist yeah and and what what's
been helpful for me is the language
because I realized that you know when I
was growing up is I hide the
entrepreneurial tendencies you know
the snow yeah you know going crazy when
I got a mark mcgwire Jose Canseco like
40 cents I'm gonna go sell this way now
you know going crazy and then and then
even I like I never got past Division
three basketball because I wouldn't play
defense as I don't play defense I just
was your Stang interesting you know man
I'm okay with Division three cuz I get I
don't have to where he play defense
right that's cool and well it's cool sup
what it's one of those things like you
know it's one of those because now I
could put language to it that I when my
dad died about 10 years ago cuz we
didn't have a good relationship at all
and then I realized that in that I mean
that's half of America reign so that's
neither here nor there but I realize
through that I cared way too much
especially older men and the way they
sawed up and like make sense and so like
I did teaching and then we moved to
Canada I actually start working for my
father-in-law going just an insurance
business
it was great like it I get stung like
never did business before I loved in his
ton of fun but then I realized again it
was kind of the golden handcuffs paid me
really well but it really wasn't my
culture so I left that went been a
pastor and is like a super fast growing
church and has a lot of fun and then
getting back to Saskatoon where we live
we're not the right fit for the culture
and so now it's one of those things like
what's most important to me is that
language is that I in order to reach
that happiness for me my family my wife
and I talk all the time about this is
that I can't worry about what other
people think and that's that's always
been my thing I got her and so now it's
a bit of I'm trying to figure out like
how do I make people aware the right
people aware of Who I am because it's
one of those things like and I have like
sought out to apply for jobs but when
I'm such a generalist and like I'll
there's everything could be fun for me
okay like I'm not locked into one thing
but right now like I you know I have
done some content over the years whether
it's belongs at dumb podcast and so I
got a website this is Rob Clark comm
basically is my full resume with
different things that I've done whether
it's professional just for fun now I'm
trying it like very practically like how
do how do I find the best situation for
my family volume yeah my entire thesis
on creative is my thesis of what you
should do I think you should apply to
7,000 jobs I I think you will get there
by applying contextually to 7,000 jobs
then spending the time to think about
which five places you should apply to I
really think that I really believe that
you know it's it's interesting how it
works
and there's a couple reasons it's fun
till I go back to back I think one of
the things that people one things that I
think I do well that's really helped me
is contextualize the moment you know I
understand what's happening currently
I'm a complete creature of the market
you know I really am deeply and I think
right now it's wild to me who's I
genuinely believe that Google would
offer you a job that like stands pizza
shop wouldn't I think we're in this
bizarro world where so much is happening
that it's that it's not the box that the
three of us grew up in everything was so
[ __ ] rigid right like I really mean
that
like I just like I'm completely
convinced of that that there's so much
progressive debate that literally right
now at Amazon they're like we need more
pastures from Canada you know that
sounds ludicrous but like I literally
believe that you know back to like
emotional intelligence like if you just
think about like the conversations that
we're having in this room I think the
thing that you know it's actually it's
so fun I keep bring it up because I
really appreciate the compliment from AJ
it's a very structured conversation
we're having around something I'm
passionate sometimes people put things
into words Tom Bell you my superpowers
not judging myself
I think what's making me resonate is I
take something that's completely grey
right but it's black and white to me
like all the answers were actually the
answers but they're not the ones that
are obvious he's funny something I talk
about all the time it embrace the
ambiguity a lot of people are so unsure
and so afraid of ambiguity right so over
time yeah or or over time you're gonna
wake up with more you're gonna say it's
black and you'll appreciate this or you
just have to change your perspective to
even see it and and and that's why you
know words matter than which really
helped
help like you know going on you know
spending eight minutes and sit and and
then and then he can say to himself
right offense versus defense it's just
so easy to understand right
I literally not joking yes I like
literally from what I'm hearing and
you've got to keep feeding me
I am excited because I really want
somebody to play this thesis out it
seems as if this becomes a game of where
do you guys want to be you know like to
me this becomes a bigger conversation
around Chattanooga Tennessee or or the
outskirts of Cleveland Ohio or sandy
eight like and again you mentioned it
quickly the six eleven son what how old
is he he's 15 and so Jesus he's just
getting into ball now and he wants a
place just now just now so he wasn't
passionate about it exactly yeah I
played a sorry I I didn't ask him to
play basketball until the date you
wanted to play smart and now he's turned
it on and he'll be okay but I want to
put him in a position to where he's just
gonna have operation is he coordinated
that's pretty good so you're thinking
about it more of like this is his key to
opportunity and so him playing at we are
is he gonna is he a smart kid he's super
smart he so this is like Ivy League like
potentially not Ivy League smart but no
he I think you want like his what is
he's yeah what does he one that he wants
to work for Disney interesting yeah no
super interest is so cool and so like
for him he wants to play pro ball just
to make enough money whether it's in
China wherever just to make enough money
because he that's his passion he's
already started a podcast on Disney for
him but so the thing is is there a way
to arbitrage that because like you know
Pez or north no no us yes that's me me I
mean so yeah 7000-8000 just keep
applying well what did it go ahead and
arbitrage that and in such a way like I
would say like we want to be in the
south the Southwest and so like anything
east of Illinois not really interested
anything north of Illinois not really
interested me and this is super like
honestly this is such a fun blank slate
like all I really want to do right now
is look at like I want to play 800
arbitrage as yeah I want to like go to a
place that's an emerging market that
fits that demo then map the 150
businesses in in the area that are
viable that could afford whatever then
figuring out the minimum
salary you need bro you're in an
incredible spot you do understand that
people spend their entire lives to put
themselves into a box and you're at a
point in your life where you've created
something that is a completely blank
slate I think that you literally go home
and you and your wife or what the kids
whatever decide in or literally have the
fun pizza dinner that says what are the
15 cities we want to be in put them in
order
map the business that are viable and
then create a contextual video to the
CEO of every one of those companies and
email it to them on LinkedIn dear Rick
in Santa Fe you know like you know I
love your tire company let me tell you
about how I sold lemonade I don't know
what else to tell you I genuinely think
that's how it works what here's why I
really like it in listening to you and
just even getting your energy my
intuition is that's exactly what you
need to do because you have to find your
match in a boss that will appreciate you
yeah right like like there's a does that
make sense
what I do can I apologize why you rarely
jump in like why did you just do that
because he's a unique word you know like
you need to find your match more
importantly than finding the career that
pays you or not I think that's what's
really working for a lot of people in
this company I'm a uniquely different
guide thus a lot of people are
succeeding here that won't succeed
elsewhere and vice versa there's a lot
of people that come in here that are
confused by why they get fired because
it worked everywhere else it's bodies
and organs and to your point you know
you know you're kind of what we're gonna
need to find the right body that makes
sense by the way like for example I hear
you talk and it's very gray right and
it's right and I'm in like in love I'm
like oh man too bad we're not in it you
know maybe what about I let you know
think you know like I love ever Ellie's
number one well great I mean like you by
the way you can flat-out email me your
lowest numbered Ellie's a little
expensive like my the running thesis is
you need to go like to somewhere weird
you know because then you're really in
the game like there is there is an
arbitrage between emerging city that
fits your profile but has enough
businesses that could actually and I
don't know where that is I don't know if
that's one of the number three city in
Arizona I don't know if that's some you
know you know but that's the Mormon
mafia you know in a great way and the
Mormon Rafa is awesome like this is like
I go with that as a positive - do you
have a best friend that you know played
at BYU like like literally like it's all
ARB it's all looking for patterns and
white spaces you have a sense of hello
the numbers it obviously maps to the
housing costs and the right the cost
right yeah yeah we're going to place my
wife and I and and we we call it a
season of drought where we've been back
in the city she grew up in in wheat for
the last four and a half years that
we've been there and this video this
video was gonna get out at some point
and a lot of her friends gonna be like
what I want to be there no she doesn't
want to be there and so it's great and
so yeah so for us her friends
subconsciously know it anyway yeah so so
ultimately we're at a place where like
cuz she's Canadian the rest of us are
American like the immigration process we
started we paid the money to lawyers are
working on it
so Suzette's done you're going then
we're going even if there's a job or not
so the 7,000 applications and make it
fun yeah enjoy it and that and that's in
again getting that language is realizing
like and I feel so bad because we're
plus we have a great or a Shana I have a
great relationship kids are healthy
they're great kids like everything's
great but still we're unhappy right and
they see that you just need to change
their environment it sounds like you're
unhappy about the micro than what you
the macro your set which is why you're
actually winning and happy so cool
[ __ ] fix the micro yeah make seven
thousand videos somebody's gonna click
I'm positive the game is changing yeah
what I used to say you know how many how
many yell across players you know you
ready for this I don't know a single
school that anybody that works me one
too I think Nick got kicked out of
[ __ ] Ryder for smoking weed one day
in I know I think I think d-roc
went to something that looks like my
mail out of college I feel like there's
like three-peat like I have no idea what
I have no [ __ ] idea but now but now
they're hiring kids with associate's
degrees which is awesome
right they would have never done that
two or three of you oh no it doesn't
[ __ ] matter doesn't matter doesn't
matter doesn't doesn't really does it
matters you can do something that
matters if you're doing Quandt work if
you know how to do math but like you
know even then I mean I wasn't a math
major because you went to nab because
you went up higher let me right right
but I had enough but I was numerous
enough well that's the point right like
like I don't because I think what
happens isn't it this is this is the
problem Wall Street mystifies the
business romantically but in a day it's
pretty simple right
even the derivatives businesses are
pretty simple everything is super simple
I don't think I don't think there's a
single job I could hold that vaynermedia
besides the one I have I'm pretty sure
maybe if we had a sales team like just
couldn't just don't have the grammar
skills to begin with I would have never
gotten into this booth
unless I interviewed directly with me
you know if it can we sneak one or two
more in I know we got one or two minutes
anything else anything else yes
question two you talked about the gray
and the black and white so I'm thinking
about goodbye to you in the company
we're doing at the moment some greyish
stuff you know from a marketing
standpoint in social media in so Canada
stock market when we are working on the
platforms like doing the DMS and posting
in the feed and commenting and all that
stuff but we figured out with our
capacity is not possible to do anything
because then we're doing it like
half-full okay and so I want to cross
out things you want to stop doing
certain things yes and wanted to ask
so we are community based so the
communities in the focus but when we are
on YouTube Facebook Instagram Pinterest
and tick tock what actions on the
certain platforms I should do not
anymore
which ones don't you like the most right
now at the moment the most capacities
have direct messages about what we heard
before direct messages are in the future
maybe I want to make sure I understand
what behavior are you doing right now
in the way that you're asking the
question what behavior right now that
your team is doing that you can't do
everything because it's half pregnant
you know you're not getting the full
value like what are you doing that you
don't think is bringing you value forget
about what we think the future is about
forget all that what are you guys doing
right now that you don't think you're
getting the most value out of okay I
want to make sure what you're doing on
direct messages give me an example from
beginning somebody tweet something or
reply to something like give it to me
yeah so somebody leaves a comment on one
of your pieces of content and then you
click that person's face and you send
them a direct message no okay you de DM
you okay hey love your stuff yeah and
you you don't think you guys can scale
replying to that person saying thank you
no we say thank you thank you for your
comment we appreciate it
what are you what I wishes in the future
for our future comments so we try to do
in conversation but the problem is that
all the comment stuff that the other
people see in the newsfeed like under
not under the feed stuff is it's not so
much attention but you're doing more
attention on direct messages verses and
feed yes why that's a great answer so
right so I think a couple things one
it's an interesting to be obviously
replying in the comments on the public
post
I do believe creates more brand of brand
value
because all of us see it and there's an
inherent unconscious feeling of oh this
brand cares it's number one it also
encourages more people to comment which
can help you in the algorithm or growth
too if you can't do both because you
don't have enough people you know one of
the things to think about is becoming
more of a global company so for example
you know the truth is you could hire
somebody in Vietnam at $2 an hour or $4
now or Poland or like you know like
these are just true conversations you
know they're there there's a lot of
arbitrage and going global you know and
so or you know and this is where Europe
sucks you know it might be harder for
you to have interns or lower cost
employees to scale everybody can scale
everything by hiring more people if they
can afford it being able to afford it is
tricky
California's harder to afford it then
Iowa Germany's harder to afford it than
America you know but you know one of the
advantages that I think European based
businesses have over American businesses
is they do think more global Americans
are funny half of us don't even have a
passport
half of us don't even realize there's a
world outside of America truly it's like
amazing yeah I mean so you know couple
things run through my mind things I
think about you know building up
capabilities in other places where the
cost goes down we're you know these are
things you can debate because they all
listen when you're talking about
touching a customer it's always a good
idea because no [ __ ]
so if you you know to me I'm a fan of
DMing and the entire yrz like we haven't
scaled it yet but I'm unbelievably
uncomfortable that we're not replying to
every person that replies to me it's
it's this it's the singular reason I
think I'm the guy there's nobody who has
the same scale of audience that I have
that reads as many comments as me I know
it to be true
and the community they write us like a
why you don't have a backpack and I say
hey how should the big thing look yeah
they sent pictures so they are R&D
they're the research and development and
you have funny like like sometimes you
ask them what it looks like and other
times you're like what do you mean wait
till next week
pre-sale on the backpack you know like
you know of course of course there's a
reason I'm write a lot it's cuz I listen
I think you should scale that you know
why not find a way always I have to
question myself when it's not working as
I want
maybe well what I think the question
becomes what's your KPI what what
success look like when you say it's not
working what's not working you want to
convert more of those people into sales
you're like yeah that's where you're
getting caught if you're it and I
appreciate you saying that because
that's the punchline you replying to
people in DMing which then inevitably on
the fourth interaction leads to would
you like to buy this or whatever maybe
or you don't do that but you analyze if
any of those people are buying that's
sales versus what I think ultimately
it's the most sales which is branding
you can't measure the fact that you
replied to him and he went out to dinner
with the three of us and said you'll
never believe this you know that
motorcycle gear that I buy i DM them
they said thank you and he's like oh
that's [ __ ] awesome
what's it again and they followed it on
an instant you can't measure that math
[ __ ] up a lot of people it sure is it
but it's a big part it's a big part but
this is an equal game of left and right
black and white versus gray math verse
heart the friction of those two things
is the magic but if I had a pick it's
always 50.1 to the gray to the heart
that's why this is called the honey
when I try to articulate what we're
doing here what's the vision honey
Empire honey over Venator kindness
empathy care culture but we're [ __ ]
empire not tryin to [ __ ] you know
build a dreamland of hypothesis I'm
trying to win out here that balance is
hard that's why the people that can do
it build big [ __ ] ass things you got
to figure out how you're measuring it
makes sense and this goes back to the
most important part cuz I think you got
a lot of things right I can feel it from
a mile away
you just have to understand timing again
if you and your partner want to sell it
in the next 24 to 36 months I'm going
into the Empire Empire got it I'm okay
with you dropping everything and
maximize it that's life but if you're
not sure and you want to build the most
leverage and it may be for a much longer
time that's when you have to not score
those things yeah in the last five years
I've made so many failures so I think
with every failure
I challenge the matrix more so they ask
you maybe for some last advice because
with this motorcycle that's that year I
want to be the number one in the world
thank you so what I advise baby who's
number one in your opinion number one is
up and starts all folks so mm-hmm and
are you judging number one based on
revenue which is fine I'm just asking
number one on revenue and experience I
give to the people so I want to give the
people the best experience they get in
this whole motorcycle rock that's what I
would spend all my time on and I know
what we get it because you you said we
have plenty of time so I have enough
time that's right
and this takes all the pressure so and
then you spend it as a girl and then you
spend all their time on the consumer
yeah because two years ago when I woke
up this morning I was like do something
every day but not like this Russia
listen work ethic matters you know as
much as its being demonized and as much
as I don't use the word as much so I can
balance out the message to make sure
people aren't confused work ethic
matters so I'm sorry you know but but
understanding what you're up to and
putting yourself in a you know where
work ethic can get very dangerous is if
it leads to you being unhappy happiness
has to be the North Star right and so if
you can lead yourself your family you
can 100% no shot no shot
yep but it's about it's about it's about
the number one thing I'm trying to think
about how to articulate now is to help
people put time and perspective
I've come to real why at 15 then I used
to play a game with myself which said oh
my god in seven years I'm gonna finally
be able to work when I'm 22 right no my
parents were gonna push me to college
and then okay and this is me at 15 okay
seven years goes eight okay eight all
right that was 83 and Edison oh that
doesn't seem that far like I've always
done that I do it today I'm 43 not to be
44 okay I've done my whole life when I'm
double I'll be 88 and I'll still be
hungry and that's probably 100 but when
I win the Super Bowl
and okay [ __ ] man I've been around for a
long time that's a lot from the day I
was born to now is 44 years and I'm
gonna do that again she's like I I think
so much of my happiness comes from
contextualizing time better than most
people I think most people are macro
impatient you know and and I think a
macro patient and I think in the micro
people are slow people are [ __ ] work
for three and a half hours or producing
or creating for three and a half hours
and in a 24 hour day but they don't know
why [ __ ] hasn't happened this year and
I'm [ __ ] on fire like I feel stressed
that I'm already four minutes over here
like literally right now I feel tension
that I know I'm forwarding to have five
minutes over right but I'm you're here
and I like wanna deliver but I'm talking
about 40 40 years from now so in the
micro I'm faster than [ __ ] but in the
macro slow as [ __ ] and so I'm literally
reverse and that's why I think I'm gonna
get everything I want and I think this
will only work if you cross all things
like I will not do this but you have to
cross out based on your paradigm not
what people told you is right the amount
of [ __ ] I do every day that makes no
[ __ ] sense would blow your mind but I
think it's right I have a major fire
over here with a client recluse for a
million bucks but I'm gonna do this Jets
podcast
I think it's right makes me happy and I
have a macro plan it's another 15 jet
fans I'm gonna convert and like I'll
make up that revenue and it's gonna
actually be alright because Katie's got
it and if she doesn't it's a good read
on Katie and like all these other
variables most things almost nothing
matters almost nothing that's where you
know you and I could see you're picking
up what I'm putting down like so I'm
happy
nothing what what make payroll right
this is what you understand this I heard
you very loud and clear this is basic
[ __ ] so people outsmart themselves
play the actual game and this is where
strategy really you know the thing that
we always talk about is the one thing
I'm not putting out to the world is that
I'm smart cuz I don't think that brings
you any value I don't know how to make
that valuable to the other person on the
other end right
I'm strategic what's that gonna mean
right I can't tell you be more strategic
be smarter like really hard that's why
work ethic was my first batting that is
the number one controllable thing
everybody listening and watching right
now could if they're so hungry if they
have such big ambitions if they're gonna
achieve so much if they have the
audacity to ask for a 1% life they could
work an extra hour instead of doing dumb
[ __ ] instead they could that felt
controllable but it goes way deeper net
it's getting the ability to see it cuz
you're in it I do it to myself too which
is what I'm good I analyze myself but
I'm still myself and sometimes you'll
hear something and it'll help you
trigger but for you it's just so simple
like it like it's so it's it becomes so
clear that you're like right that is
actually what's happening and now you
get to make a decision even if you
decided to stay the course and decided
to hold your breath because you
appreciate your lifestyle in the three
to five year window you've decided and
it goes wrong just the fact that you
knew you were doing it it's still gonna
feel better right that 1% right same
game which is like any brother if there
is a point O 3 cent I'm telling you
right now and [ __ ] that you said the NDA
you know where you can go and where you
can't go like get it all out that
doesn't get you sued and even its point
three that's the magic
that's it and then you're [ __ ] on top
then what eight-mile [ __ ] love that
I'd bring it up all the time I know you
guys consume my content all the time
real tough for clearance to dis him when
he [ __ ] dissed himself
you